last year this was London's teen murder
capital
on the streets of Croydon five young
lives lost to knife crime
the youngest victim was 14 year old
Jermaine cools his memory is always
always have meant that I always see him
in my my vision I was talking like talk
to him
his father Julius has turned his
Caribbean takeaway into a tribute while
he continues to rule the reasons for the
violence we're just living in a world
like right now which is crazy
and some of the people that have no love
in the heart and they don't they don't
care and a lot of innocent people is
just getting hurt
those words explain why he did this last
month intervening to snatch a knife and
save a woman from the same fate as
Jermaine
if I can protect somebody from getting
hurt I will do it because I don't want
any parents to go for the same pain I'm
going through it's not the easy one
and his back pain will never go away
statistics show incidents like that are
becoming rarer Croydon has seen no fatal
teen stabbings this year so far
thanks in part to the work of this man
how do we pick up on real issues and
have the real conversations
his police training sessions led by
young people have helped Bridge a gap
and build trust meaning more Vital
Information is shared
and it's interesting when we get the
young people to feed back they start
speaking about when they're shopping in
Croydon or they're walking through on
the road how officers are shaking hands
and embracing them or officers remember
that they're the ones that was on the
training on the onboarding sessions so
things like that have built relationship
and it influences how police police our
communities in a culturally appropriate
way
I kept hearing a phrase it takes a
village to raise a child I think I
really understood that until quite
recently and I think what we've done
working with the community down here is
we built that Village and we've got
people now who come together and work
with us to try and keep the children
safe
[Music]
that's not the only thing turning the
tables on life crime here though there
are more than a dozen recently launched
projects
[Music]
including this DJing program offering
music mentoring and most importantly a
place to go
just doing nothing but I feel like
because there's now this I have like
more things to do with life so it's like
helping
me from being lazy and just not doing
anything I don't know that why why in
like this generation is it like this
like why can't like people who are like
doing bad things be like this like if
they had an opportunity that they had
like when they was like my age they
wouldn't be doing the same thing
[Music]
protecting young people from life crime
is complex but their own words speak to
the simple part of the solution
taking action early the caps shingi
marike Sky News Croydon in South London